hey what is up my name is samuel leeds
and i am a property investor and on this
video
i am going to be answering a whole bunch
of property investment questions
from last week's video i'm going to
answer them right now
on this video and on top of that here's
what i'm going to do for you right now
you can comment your questions in the
comment box below
and i am actually going to answer your
property investment questions
i've been investing in property for 12
years i've done over 300
property deals i'm the best-selling
author of buy low rent high which is a
property investment book
and all i ask for in return is that you
smash
the like button turn the subscribe
button notification bell on and comment
your questions below let's see what
we've got from last week
zach collins says samuel recently found
your channel and i'm looking to start my
journey on
buy to let i have a few family members
who currently do this and close friends
who work in sales
so let's and letting so i have some good
contacts my question is
how do you push yourself to get that
first house and i'm worried about making
the jump
i am able to purchase a residential home
so zach what i would say is okay a few
things firstly
before you make any investment decision
you need to look
at the worst case scenario so it's good
to be skeptical it's good to be
you know not necessarily just jumping
and jumping and jumping in you're a bit
like worried
so let's look at this factually
logically what's the worst case so when
are you about to
spend money on a property whether it be
a home to live in whether it be a home
to rent out
you're going to say what's the worst
thing that could happen realistically
okay
of course there could be a plague and
everybody could die but with this
investment what's going to be the worst
case
then look at the best case then look at
the likely case
and then you need to work out how can
you de-risk so if the worst case is
the the there will be no tenant and it
will be a bad tenant and
if you say okay well how can i de-risk
that maybe i can buy in a better area
maybe i can find a really good
management company so you're gonna
de-risk it
and then look at the new after you've
de-risked it what's the best case what's
the worst case what's the likely case
and then once you've looked at
everything you've looked at the best
you've looked at the worst you look to
the likely then i'd ask yourself
what would you advise your best friend
to do if you wanted your best friend to
win
what would you suggest they do and if
you you've done the risk assessment
you know that you'd advise your friend
to do it you then
just need to stop being a little [ __ ]
and you just need to take action and do
it
like that's all i can say in business
you're gonna have to continually be
stretching yourself and growing
and that's just it and feel the fear and
do it anyway so that's what i would say
zach
respect for being on the channel and
commenting and uh
go kick some ass and i hope that helps
all right dan pound
says samuel i come from a wealthy family
they've given me forty thousand pound
and it's sitting in my
bank account lucky you
what can i do with it uh with property
because i don't wanna just waste my
money on liabilities but rather spend it
on assets
all right so firstly uh great stuff that
you've got 40 000 pounds sat in your
bank
uh also congratulations on not just
spending it many people will just be
like wow 40 grand and they'd spend it
and i actually think being in a wealthy
family whereby you're giving 40 grand
if you do just spend it you're actually
gonna be hindered because
now you've not got money because you've
spent it but you've got high standards
and becoming financially free when
you've been you know muddy cuddled your
life
is actually really difficult so
congratulations dan on saying i want to
invest this i want to be smart i want to
take this see this as an opportunity
except that i'm fortunate and now i want
to become financially independent so
what can you do with it 40 grand well
firstly
um you're investing in property i i'd
say that your family are really
supportive so maybe if you say you're 17
maybe you can get a one of your family
members to be a mortgage host for you
i would take that 40 grand i would put
it into a property uh
i'd push the value up and i'd refinance
it and i'd say to your family hey
i invested the 40 grand into a property
but guess what i got the 40 grand back
because i bought a house i got bridging
development finance
i pushed the value up and now i've
refinanced it on a normal buy to let
mortgage
thanks for the 40 grand thanks for being
my mortgage host for me
i've got the 40 grand back and i'm going
to do it again and then might be like
holy moly
here's another 40. in fact here's 400
let's scale this thing so
not only would i invest it well into
property but i'd really want to make it
count because i'd want to show
your family what you've done with it um
because potentially they might partner
with you again
and that's not that's not you being um
you know like a sponge or whatever
you can't rely on your family continuing
to give you gifts but what you can do is
you can
prove and demonstrate that you've been a
good investor with that money
and then they'll want to they'll want to
continue investing hope that helps
joel says hi samuel my wife and i just
bought our house in may i'm keen to get
started in property one of the ways i
thought of doing this was through
refinancing and using the money towards
deposits in either buy toilets or brrs
my question is is it worth me
refinancing now or waiting for a couple
of years for property
for the property to go up in value or is
deal sourcing and raising finances my
only options
thanks so much really love your content
and boldness ps i've also joined samuel
365
and loving it respect joel i do all of
the above
okay so rather than thinking should i be
doing deal sourcing should i be raising
finance or should i be
taking my own equity from a house i'd
refinance it straight away
and then put it into another investment
and while you're looking for another
investment the investments that you see
that aren't quite for you
but a decent i'd sell them and pass them
to other investors and i'd take that
cash flow and put it towards my next
deposit
um and then once you've done that you've
sold a few deals you've refinanced to
put it to an investment
and you've proven yourself scale this
thing and then start tapping into other
people's mind i'll do everything
good job cooking delight recipes i have
a popular question samuel
okay i'm 28 single i'm currently living
at home with my mom
i'm currently saving for a deposit to
buy my first home but i'm not sure if i
should a
use the deposit mode to buy my first
home which would mean i finally move out
of my mom's house and officially begin a
life of independence
or b use it to buy an investment
property instead
and rent it out i'll then use the rental
profit to save up again
for a new deposit for my first home this
would mean staying at home for a few
more years though please give me your
honest opinion
i would say if you if you're happy to
stay at home it's cheaper
it's much cheaper the only reason i'd
move out would be if you're thinking
look when i'm 28 and i feel like if i
have my own space i'd be able to achieve
more b
more so staying at home is a decent
option um
however i would probably personally at
28 i'd move out but don't think
moving out means you have to buy your
own home i'd use the money i'd invest in
property and i'd
rent somewhere and i'd become an i'd be
an investor but also an entrepreneur
you've got to make money make more money
invest more money
uh so yeah i'd probably do neither of
the above i didn't
i would move out rent and then buy an
investment property
of course it's your decision um bungie
says hi samuel i have a really important
question
i wanted to ask for a long time and that
is
should i migrate to the usa because real
estate in america has huge apartments
which bring
way more monthly cash flow or should i
stay in the uk and just focus on focus
on hmo type properties
even though they will take longer to
accumulate do whatever you know
okay united states of america great
investment opportunities there
in the uk in germany in in the
netherlands
there's great opportunities pretty much
everywhere you just need to
invest in what you know if you're in the
uk and you know the uk market pretty
well but you've just seen a shiny penny
in the usa
oh that looks better sometimes the grass
is greener on the other side so
but i don't know if that is the case do
what you know stick to what you know
tweak it make it make it as good as you
can vinnie morris more on my question
okay this must have been from last week
thanks for your reply samuel sorry my
question wasn't clear
my my plan if possible was to sell my
house and use that money to buy a place
in need of refurbishment with a bridging
loan
and the fifty thousand pound equity also
use the bridging loan for the refurb
then refinance on a residential mortgage
and pull out all the money to do a brr
over and over so my question is would
this be possible thanks so much for your
help
vinnie yes it is possible that when you
refinance it you probably want to do it
on a
buy to that mortgage not a residential
mortgage in principle
that's exactly right that is buy
refurbish
refinance rent and you want to put your
money in pull your money out
recycle your cash and do that again and
again and again as many times as you can
um and frizzy do you have any book
recommendations specifically about
property i've read your books
as well as other stairs simon's um
listen
um you mean i mean the thing is you've
read mine you've read other books
um maybe you need to just start doing it
maybe you need to start getting around
investors books are great
but when you want to get specific
property knowledge
books can be difficult because sometimes
they're written a few years back and
they can get a bit out of date
you want to get a mentor really that can
just tell you what to do abc
get around other investors that are
doing it keep reading
uh obviously rich dad poor dad from
robert kiyosaki
there's a lot of books that were i like
books that were written a very long time
ago that are still applicable today
like rich dad poor dad but also like
things like the science of getting rich
think and grow rich the richest man in
babylon basically anything that includes
rich in the title and i'm just i'm just
kidding
but property wise it is limited you just
want to get around people are doing it
okay
uh i've written a couple of books as
well i've written um
bilo rent high i've also written
financially free in seven days
how i did that my brother russell's
written a book called the entrepreneur's
blueprint that's really good
uh hope that helps all right matt
dempsey
many by select lenders still require a
minimum annual income for the applicant
i don't know if that's a question i
don't think it is i get the feeling matt
that i probably said that some don't and
now you're going some do though some
require
a minimum annual income and listen matt
like
you'll always be able to find some
lenders that can't help you you'll
always be able to find some banks that
will say no
you'll always be able to find some
estate agents to say they don't do rent
to rents you'll always be able to find
some investors that say um
you know you can't you can't do this
that any other but
you don't want to be you any broke ass
idiot can find problems and can find
people that say it can't be done
but as a entrepreneur you need to be
finding solutions
so last week if i said that there's
lenders out there
that don't care about how much your
annual income is you should be going
awesome you only need one you only need
one lender that will say that
it's very easy to find lenders that will
say i know you do
but stop looking for the negative bro
stop you know i can tell straight away
from from that question
that you're not financially independent
at first it's not a question it's a
statement
so you know broke people look for
problems rich
people look for solutions poor people
have a lot of excuses because it doesn't
cost anything to come up with an excuse
so yeah that's my response to your
statement and hopefully that will change
the way you think slightly you might be
angry at me right now samuel's a dick i
don't do this because i want to be liked
i do this because i want to help people
become financially independent
all right louise hall i'm completely new
and trying to learn as much as possible
just wondering where i can find
investors you can find investors
there's groups there's little groups and
networks and clusters all across the
world
but you can also go on facebook i've got
a facebook group called property
investors with samuel leaves there's
over 28 000 property investors on the
group
social media is amazing ralph quick
question when you buy a house for a
hundred thousand pounds with a 25
deposit then after some time it's worth
150
how much can you pull out from it is it
75
from 150 minus 25 deposit paid earlier
uh can you please explain that i've
heard two different stories
um yeah it is it's so it's 75
of the new value so if the new values
150
000 pounds 75 that's going to be
a hundred and twelve thousand five
hundred so that's gonna in my head i
might be wrong but i think that's right
so
that's gonna be your new mortgage but
with that money you're gonna need to pay
off your old mortgage
which was 75 of a hundred which is 75
grand
so you're going to pay off the 75 grand
with the 112
500 but then you're going to be you're
going to have what 37
grand roughly in in equity and you don't
pay tax on that money you can use that
money to go put to
put another deposit in another house so
that's
how it works okay i hope that helps aj
why
samuel i've been looking to help to buy
houses as they acquire a small deposit
are you able to then rent them out
help to buy is a scam by the government
okay
this is my opinion but help to buy is a
scam
by the government i would say no do not
do it
um are you then able to rent them out no
you're not
no you're not see the system wants you
to be poor okay
and you might think samuel that's not
right but but but it just is
i mean help to buy here's what it is
they'll say you can just put down five
percent
and they'll they'll put they'll pay the
rest of the deposit but they don't pay
it they lend it you
so effectively you're getting a 95 loan
and you're putting down five percent but
you're restricted on what you can buy
i mean normally you've just got to buy
new builds and then what the developers
do is they push the value up because
they know that suckers will come along
and help to buy
so you'll be buying overpriced new build
houses
it's all right for me i'm a developer
but it's not right for you
um then you've got to pay the the loan
back and the government back
you can't rent it out you have to live
there if the whole system wants you to
buy a house
live in it and pay off the mortgage
and have a job and retire at 67
and then die that's what the system
wants and and it's so ridiculous
that they'll say they'll say oh the
banks will say
no you can't get a a family member to
loan you the deposit
you can't do that because then you'll be
over leveraged but the government oh
they can lend you the deposit
even though you want a family member to
loan you a deposit to buy an investment
house
too risky but an investment house is an
investment
where you can pay them back easily
because you've got a tenant in there but
it's not too risky
for the government to learn the deposit
where it's not even an investment you're
living there it's a liability
come on get real like it's a scam
so you know people say samuel your
training courses are a scam you rip
people off i'm like
are you stupid like look
look look at what the government are
doing look at help to buy schemes
look at college and university where
they charge
9 000 pounds a semester i mean i'm not
saying
i'm not saying universities are a scam
but the whole way the system
is it's designed for you to be poor so
sorry if i got a little bit uh preachy
there or something but
i'm passionate about that all right last
question sugar lolly
hey samuel i recently had a baby and
after three months of motherhood i don't
want to go back to work
i want to rent my current home and move
to a better area for school so i'm
currently living in a 500 000 pound
house with a 150 000 pound mortgage left
on it what would you recommend i do
so you've got 350 000 pound equity i'd
sell the house right now while we're in
a mini burn
i'd take that full 500 000 pounds and i
would invest it smart into property and
i'd put a little bit into your education
um and i would then rent where you live
that's what i would do
that's my opinion i'm not a tax advisor
i'm not a financial advisor i'm not
regulated by the government if i was
regulated by the government i couldn't
say this stuff
not because it's wrong but because you
can't talk about like
listen um the schools are regulated okay
the curriculums are regulated by the
government and what are they teaching
about money they're either teaching
absolutely nothing
or they're teaching a pile of absolute
nonsense that's my opinion
let me know your opinion also let me
know your thoughts questions comments
i'll answer them next week below if you
enjoy my channel
listen i don't get paid to do youtube i
don't even monetize most of my videos
uh if you enjoy my channel smash the
like button subscribe comment below
i'll see you next time
you